neben im englischen norfolk dass kate
mit ihrem mann jeff führt in wenigen
tagen feiern sie ihren 45
hochzeitstag mit einem großen fest der
held auf einen brief der alles verändert
katja jobs freundin vor über 50 jahren
verunglückte sie bei einer bergtour
jetzt ist ihre leiche gefunden worden
verdrängt es bricht auf jobs ehefrau
gerät ins abseits
charlotte rampling als kate schöpft
dabei aus eigenen erfahrungen
lebensereignisse können dich zerreißen
andere mögen das vielleicht nicht
verstehen was in dir vorgeht darum geht
es in dieser geschichte und wie eine
veränderung die plötzlich den boden
unter den füßen wegzieht bleibt zunächst
besonnen bereitet das fest vor
wenn rampling alltäglich handelt wird
ein beginnender prozess spürbar
das fest rückt näher
noch versteht cage obwohl der sich immer
intensiver mit dem damals beschäftigt
ramblings kunst oft nur ein
nachdenklicher blick der den bruch
sichtbar macht und für einen moment
scheint es doch als während 45 jahre ehe
stärker als der konflikt
die fremdheit spürt man bei dem
alternden paar obwohl es auch unerwartet
ausgelassenen momente zwischen ihnen
gibt
jon courtney spielt seine figur
grummelig ein wenig verloren heute seine
jugend es ist vorbei darüber denkt er
sein leben neu und wie ideales hätte
sein können aber nie wurde so spitzt
sich die situation zu lange
einstellungen eine abweisende drehung im
bett behutsame filmische mittel die die
zunehmende distanz zwischen dem paar
deutlich machen werden und charlotte
rampling spielen das paar mit fast
unbewegten mienen und minimalen gesten
verdeutlichen so dessen hilflosigkeit
die unsicherheit ob sie sich noch mögen
oder nicht begleitet den ganzen du hast
nicht einfach auf jemanden zu lieben nur
irgendetwas aufbricht selbst dann nicht
wenn es da ein echtes geheimnis gibt
aber was ist wenn die verletzung zu tief
sitzt auch für den zuschauer wird diese
leise geschichte zur herausforderung so
intensiv wie sie auch gespielt ist
es gibt doch der